dans les rues de Kiev il s'activent les
électriciens multiplient les
interventions pour rétablir le courant
avant la tombée de la nuit la tâche est
immense dans tout le pays les foyers
sans électricité au chauffage se
comptent par millions après les frappes
russes de ces derniers jours sur des
installations énergétiques c'est ce
qu'affirme le président ukrainien venu
constater les dégâts dans cette rue
Stallone
ce vendredi des coupures se poursuivent
dans la plupart des régions plus de 6
millions de foyers au total mercredi
soir c'était 12 millions la plupart des
problèmes se situent actuellement dans
la capitale ainsi que dans les régions
d'Odessa de le vif de Vinicia et de ni
pro
avec la nuit le froid s'ajoute à
l'obscurité il faut se chauffer alors
que le thermomètre affiche des valeurs
négatives s'éclairer avec des bougies
dans ce magasin ou avec une torche pour
opérer dans cet hôpital
voilà dans quelles conditions pratiquent
la chirurgie cardiaque aujourd'hui
regardez ça
en attendant le retour du courant les
habitants peuvent recharger leur
téléphone et se réchauffer dans ces
tentes installés par la mairie
ce vendredi la présidence ukrainienne a
critiqué la mise en place de ses centres
d'aide à la population par la
municipalité de Kiev volo dimireski la
juge de mauvaise qualité